all right the destroyed truck media has
become totally unhinged over the raid of
our president Trump's personal attorney
Michael Cole with some of them going so
far as to question if Donald Trump could
take action in Syria as a distraction
like the movie wag the dog even though
he announced it before the rain take a
look the news simply does not come much
bigger than this with President Trump
weighing military action against Syria
the FBI takes action against his
personal attorney and president Trump
lashes out big time
Larry Levenson last week I've been
reminded he's the bootys the director
that found where a president in fiction
decides to start a little war to cover
up for a hanky-panky
I remember Reagan was a lot of people
thought he started that little action
down into Grenada and cover up for
Beirut and lots of the marine lives
right it isn't so far-fetched we have a
temper mentally unfit men man who is now
having to make decisions on what may be
a decision that not only impacts the the
future of Syria but the entire region
the seriousness of the situation in the
within the White House right is
interesting at this time if he wants to
do a wag the dog in Syria the timing of
this he had announced the threat of a
potential reaction within 24-48 hours
before that had happened joining us now
with reaction NRA TV contributor and
former Secret Service agent Dan Mangino
as well as the co-host of the steel and
ungar's show Sirius XM POTUS Rick Ungar
is with us Obama drew your friend Obama
the one you love so much Rick good to
see you again you've been a stranger
you've been you've abandoned our program
you know I'm back you totally abandoned
us that I heard of mine Gina was here so
I had to come back oh yeah of course you
come from bond Gina yeah here's the
point Obama drew a red line in the sand
did nothing and it's only embolden Assad
Kerry announced to the world he's gotten
rid of a hundred percent of his of his
chemical weapon arsenal not true no
that's really not true the redline
resolution was supposed to involve the
UN and Russia getting those weapons out
of there clearly that did not happen
your
right about Carrie I can't argue with
you and even that what President Trump
did which I supported I will tell you
disagree since you've been here last did
you let me get this well I just tell the
truth you should know that by now even
what he did did not apparently go far
enough I actually support the president
doing something in Syria we cannot sit
by and let Assad do what he did to those
poor people in that suburb outside of
Damascus however all of that is not
going to stop media liberal or otherwise
from seeing a wag the dog scenario I
have a suggestion for the president the
Congress the Senate is looking at a new
bill that they're going to introduce on
Thursday to reset up the War Powers it's
a Republican sponsored bill if I were
the president yes if I were the
president in this situation I would
discuss this with the hominy bad idea
he's the commander-in-chief and Congress
has the power according to the
constitution in ways they do under the
but every president no president has
listened to the War Powers Act Dan they
should you're right John the media you
have to understand and I know you get
this but the audience needs to
understand this as well the media
understands and sees everything with
regard to their disdain for Trump do the
Russian collusion lends everything
they've gas-lit they they've been
gaslighting themselves where they tell a
lie over and over comes not confidently
and they isolate themselves from the
truth so what they see here is they see
this as a wag the dog effort despite the
obvious fact that Trump has been very
harsh on the Russians you know he wiped
out a bunch of Russian mercenaries
mercenaries over in Syria
he's been basically trying to bankrupt
their natural gas market he just
sanctioned seven Russian oligarchs with
direct contact with Putin Deripaska and
Viktor Vekselberg
included I mean they're just losing
their minds and their disdain for Trump
is colouring them to the reality right
in front of them and it's really
embarrassing them not us are you gonna
defend your liberal friends in the media
Rick even though you're beginning to see
the light a little bit you cannot blame
them Sean it's unrealistic to think that
they're not going to notice the
possibilities here this is why didn't
Trump announce 24 to 48 hours but
before we heard about the raid on
Michael Cohen's office yeah but see
that's what yes he did but look at the
wood he announced a week before that the
week before that the president says I'm
getting out of Syria then a couple of
days after that it's well maybe now it's
that soon and now it's in 24 to 48 hours
before we ever heard that Michael Cole
by the way I wish would raid the DOJ and
the FBI and grab their computers damn
Bungie no Rick you got the timeline all
messed up you just acknowledged it he
said yes we may be getting out of Syria
then the gas attack happened and then
the Cowan raid it's Rick your son listen
I know your first warning ray you've got
the whole thing yeah you've got the
whole thing mixed up Rick I don't think
so that's what I just said he did say
that before the gas attack people like
me were going why are you getting out so
soon and why are you announcing it when
you're the one who hates with a lot of
embassies it time out but sure but
serious questions Sean just says I'd
like the answer to that how come just
don't you just call out the media and
say all right guys this is obviously not
a wag the dog scenario because the
timeline does not marry up to that yeah
it's literally no sense yeah I think
it's unrealistic to expect that media is
not going to see the possibilities here
I want him to do something yet Hank
that's irrational both of you
Rick Ungar kind of welcome back you
almost there